luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome
back to the lehigh pen show it is powered by
icon plus capital the vc firm so today is a really
interesting topic the world has gone pretty crazy
recently um a kind of division that i haven't
seen in my lifetime so i'm going to delve into
this with a good friend of mine but before
i do i just want to let you know that this
is as usual sponsored by blockfi you can get
amazing interest rates with them and i think
around 250 when you sign up and this particular
episode is actually sponsored by compass mining
huge thanks to them because without them obviously
we won't be able to make these amazing shows and
really just like speak the truth so um compass
mining so they actually make bitcoin mining
accessible for everyone you just buy your machine
pick a hosting facility and let them do the work
so if you do want to start mining bitcoin then
just head to compassmining.io so let's start the
show joining me today is the founder and co-host
of trigonometry it is constant kissing constant
how are you doing i'm good leah it's pronounced
constantine by the way constantine i'm sorry i
didn't get that fully right that's all right
now officially racist uh no oh my god stop it
i i love it when people get into that
mispronouncing people's name sahar makes
you you know a bigger it makes me laugh but i'm
good it's good to be with you i've been uh we've
been following each other for a while on social
media i really enjoy the stuff that you put out
and maybe you can explain to me what bitcoin is
all about uh i think i told you uh in like 2011 or
something i bought half a bitcoin for four hundred
dollars uh and i was like whatever i held on to it
for about three or four years and when i checked
back into my account it was worth twice as much as
what i ported for so i was like oh my god this is
amazing i better sell this before this crashes and
so i got eight hundred dollars for a bitcoin uh
so you know that's my the extent of my experience
with it wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i just need to like press you on that sorry how
much bitcoin did you say you had i had a bitcoin
just one bitcoin and you sold it for 800 pounds
yeah oh my god that is crazy
how do you feel about it
well you know i'm jewish right so how
am i supposed to feel about losing money
stop i hate the like i'm really bad with jokes
like that like i'm okay so i don't get offended
easily but i i get really weird with like jokes
like that i don't know why it just makes me feel
so funny but i hear you i hear you okay i'm with
you i'm with yeah that's that's the whole point of
jokes to make people feel uncomfortable i actually
agree with you so before we delve in i'm actually
going to press you on this before we delve into
it just can you tell people about your background
obviously um you know you're the co-host of the
trigonometry podcast um great show watched it love
it tell people about it and also where it came
from well so the long story short is that i'm
originally from russia i was born in the soviet
union in the early 80s my parents sent me to
boarding school in the 90s in the uk when my
dad was very briefly a sort of mini oligarch
before he lost all his money uh and that's why i
ended up in the uk uh i initially i had to drop
out of university because my my family ran out
of money because actually my dad was um he was
accused falsely of various things and russia
had to escape russia under a false name and
as a result of that lost all his money he was a
minister in boris yeltsin's government at the time
um and as a result of that i actually ended up at
university halfway through university not having
enough money to even be able to uh carry on with
my studies not only that i didn't even have enough
money to pay rent and i ended up sleeping on the
street for about three weeks uh in in scotland
in in in the scottish summer uh before eventually
you know starting my own business with translation
which was what i did for for about 10 years had a
lot of success with that i was probably you know
the number one translator in my language pair and
in my fields i then started teaching other people
the business skills of of that particular industry
how to negotiate with clients i studied a lot of
psychology nlp hypnotherapy all that sort of like
communication stuff which i found very useful and
then i got very bored of it because to me the
thing about life is always want to be moving
forward and once you get to a point in an industry
or in a field where it's like you've got nothing
else to do i kind of wanted to move on and be bad
at something again so i started comedy and that's
how i became a comedian in about 2014 2015 i did
that for a few years and i very quickly realized
that the industry i was now in was going in
a direction that was very unexpected to me so
to me comedy was always about uh challenging
the na the narratives that we're being
fed by the mainstream about questioning things
about pointing out things that don't make sense
about society and all of those sort of things
and i thought when i went into comedy later
that that is where people like me go like if you
want to push back if you want to challenge things
you go into comedy uh and what happened i i
very quickly discovered actually that that's
completely not true uh comedy is full of the most
atrocious conformism and group think and heard
mentality that you could imagine and partly as
a pushback to that but partly also as a pushback
to many of the things that happen in society
more broadly which i'm sure we'll talk about
uh i realized that i wanted to understand what
was happening because as a dark-skinned immigrant
to britain who voted romaine who thought you know
all this liberal stuff was gray and blah blah blah
what happened in 2016 for me was i've lived
in this country for nearly over 20 years now
and people started saying to me people who were
my friends people who i'd known for many years
well the reason this country voted to leave
the uk is that this is a racist country
and i was like well that's just not true i i just
know that through my own experience i'm not saying
no one's ever been rude or bigoted towards me but
that doesn't necessarily mean that the country
itself is racist or that there are many people
like that right i grew up in russia where uh there
were plenty of stupid people who were prejudiced
and bigoted against others so to me this i just i
just knew that wasn't true right that explanation
of the things that started happening in 2016
was not accurate and so my friend and co-host
francis foster who we do trigonometry with we
were like well let's start a show where we try
and understand we talk to people who actually
understand what's going on why this particular
thing happened about what's going on and that's
really the genesis of trigonometries two
comedians asking questions in order to try
and mitigate their own ignorance in some way i'm
really fascinated by the fact that you said you
went into comedy because you thought that that
is where people go to talk and express themselves
you know and challenge the norm because that
is never ever how i've ever perceived comedy
comedy is yeah gone well i was going to say you're
probably a fair bit younger than me so you may not
have not not have been around when people like big
bill hicks and george carlin uh and other richard
pryor these are all probably before your time and
these were comedians who who they were very funny
but the purpose of their shows was also to make
you think and to make you question things and if
you if you get a chance to go back and have a look
at some of their clips you'll see that these are
people who are really asking you to not buy into
the system to go what is wrong with the picture
you know whether it was and it was on all sorts
of issues it was whether you know is the american
dream really that realistic george carlin has a
great bit about it he has brilliant bits about
the erosion of language where he talks about how
certain words are being substituted now and again
i'm sure we'll talk about that that is something
that's happening in a very big way at the moment
um you know where's bill hicks he talked a lot
about for example why you know he talked a lot
about drugs he was a guy who took drugs he smoked
and he loved all of that and he talked about how
it seems like all the drugs that we're allowed to
take uh alcohol tobacco uh you know i'm having a
cup of tea right now all the things that we're
allowed to do they are all things that allow
you to function in the normal society and be a
good drone right whereas the drugs that open your
mind the drugs that make you think creatively
the drugs that make you question should i be
going to a nine-to-five job should i be taking
orders from some boss i don't like should have
he was saying well maybe let's have a think about
why that's happening right so he bill hicks was
someone who was a bit more conspiratorial in his
thinking uh but the point was that he was someone
who made you think and he made you question things
um and he became quite iconic because he died
very young uh and and so these were the people
that inspired me to go into comedy whereas you and
it's this is the generational divide you've
probably grown up watching tv loads of woke
people running their their crap down your throat
on tv because that's who that's comedy right and
that's and you know i feel so bad for you and your
generation because you've really missed out on the
on what i think were the golden days of comedy and
maybe i hope that the pushback against this woke
stuff that you've been watching on tv and people
of your age have been i hope the pushback against
that generates a new golden age of comedy i've
kind of been rather hopefully predicting that that
would happen for some time it's not happening just
yet but it is starting to happen people like ryan
long and others doing comedy of of a different
slan i think it will potentially be something in
the future that i'm really excited about yeah i
should take back that initial statement because
actually i'm a huge charlie chaplin fan um i think
his work is so beautiful it really speaks to me
on like a humor level but also on a spiritual
level um the music as well and yeah of course
charlie chaplin totally um you know stuck it to
the man stuck it to the system and everything
so no you're totally right um so when for you did
you think that shift really changed because really
if you know you go into comedy and you think that
this is all about um questioning the establishment
and then suddenly it's actually not and in my
lifetime from what i've seen comedy is just a
bunch of woke people other than michael mcintyre
who's excellent um you know he stays away from
that um you must have really noticed a change in
society at what point was that well i think as we
were talking about earlier it was it was probably
around brexit and the election of donald trump
that just seemed to explode people's heads and i
know i was someone like i say it was probably uh
left leaning i was i don't think i was ever woke
but i was certainly not you know on the far right
or on the right or whatever this all this nonsense
is i was just someone who i've always thought that
the most important thing in life is to make your
own mind up about things to look at the evidence
to judge things as you see them to judge people
as you see them and not to allow yourself to to
get embroiled in other people's emotional
incontinence about what's happening right
and i think what we've seen over the last five
years is that a lot of people they want to do
that they want to see everything through the prism
of this is the worst thing that's ever happened
these people are evil anyone who disagrees with me
is the worst possible person i think social media
obviously has a huge part to play in this it's
amplified the divisions and it made them deeper
and more painful um so i think it was around those
two triggers i think brexit and trump really sent
a lot of people absolutely nuts and seeing that
troubles me because you know growing up in the
soviet union and my most of my family were
uh were in the gulags in one shape or form
or another for the things that they said that they
were not supposed to say or for the wrong opinions
that they had or for something they'd done to
me seeing a society descend into unthinking
seeing a society descend into this herd mentality
where we're all like sheep and we're all supposed
to follow some particular narrative because cnn
or the new york times or the guardian of the bbc
uh are pumping this stuff out to me that was very
worrying and it's the same thing now and again i'm
sure we'll talk about it when i see the unthinking
when it comes to lockdowns and masks and whatever
no look the pandemic is real and of course people
have to take precautions and all of that but
when the science says you know masks don't seem
to work right and in fact one of the things i
noticed straight away when the mask mandates came
out was i predicted that it would actually make
covert easier to spread because what happens when
put on people put on mask is like when people put
on bicycle helmets they become more confident and
in in the case of mass it means they stop socially
distancing and it's the first thing that happened
right so you've got this situation where people
are making decisions based on what that makes them
feel good or makes them feel virtuous as opposed
to what's actually real and that's to me is very
worrying because i've seen societies descend
and i've read about societies and my family
has lived in societies that descended into this
emotional thing that becomes a snowball effect and
people aren't that they're almost like their brain
isn't there anymore they're just part of some
kind of brain big brain operation and they're all
following in one direction without thinking for
themselves and that bothers me a lot there yeah
it's like yuri basmanov said there's this like
really famous clip which i watch all the time um
i'm slightly obsessed with this topic um but you
know he sort of says you society won't know what
is coming until you physically feel um you know
whether it's like the pain or you know just not
to quote exactly but until you're like taken to
the gas chambers basically like you won't know
what is coming until it is literally there so my
question to you is why is that this clamp down on
you know freedom of speech dialogue conversation
because i'll tell you this you and i haven't said
anything derogatory yet we haven't said anything
controversial just yet and i can tell you give
me time give you time i cannot i can tell you for
a matter of fact that my monetization on youtube
just because of a few things we have said
will be limited i will then have to actively
um request for it to be put back to normal and it
probably will because we haven't said anything bad
but it you know it's just that like if we were
talking about feminism and we were like you know
women are oppressed and you know we need to
help the women even help the jews as well you
know both jewish we can speak openly um you
know then it probably wouldn't be um limited
but why is it starting even with brexit you know
back then it like for me i do think brexit was a
key turning point in the uk when those divisions
really started because obviously just for the
people who aren't british mostly an american
following the uk has always been very calm
it's been very calm we never had huge
tensions um just another thing i'll say
before it is like i remember when i was younger
and i was maybe about 12 or 13. i i remember when
an election was going on and i thought to myself
god imagine living in the 60s when like your vote
really mattered wouldn't it be really cool if
your vote matters wouldn't it be really cool to
like protest and fight for something because now
society is just boring years later here we are so
this division you know not being allowed
to say things where did that come from
well there's a lot of different answers to that
question because there are many it's a complicated
subject there are technological factors uh there
are there are social factors there are historical
factors so one of the things i think 2016 was
really about and donald trump if you've got a
mostly american audience everything we say about
brexit will apply equally uh to the election of
donald trump uh i think uh 2016 represented uh
working class people mostly working-class people
being fed up of being ruled by an elite that
increasingly didn't care about their concerns
so as the jobs were being shipped off to china and
the united states as in the uk people were coming
in from eastern europe and look i'm an immigrant
from eastern europe myself i've got nothing
against people coming to a different country and
trying to make a better life for themselves but
when a large number of people come into a country
in a short period of time it causes tension it
causes downward pressure on wages it causes people
to lose their jobs it causes competition for
housing in the society which already has a problem
with with housing so this was happening but the
elites the people who were making the political
decisions their experience of those processes
was completely different their jobs weren't being
shipped off their jobs weren't being lost their
wages weren't falling they were getting cheaper
nannies coming even coming in from eastern europe
and looking after their their privileged kids so
so the people making the decisions had lost touch
completely with the majority of society with
ordinary people and so to me 2016 was an outcry
from those people who were given for the first
time in a long time an opportunity to say enough
listen to us as well and i think that is what
happened in 2016 and of course the pampered
elite who've had their hands on the tiller for
all this time didn't like that they didn't want
people to be able to say what they're saying
that's why they they got all their trump cards
out the racism stuff the bigotry the xenophobia
all of that stuff became so big because it was a
tool that they used to try and shut people up so
that's the political part of it the technological
part of it is the truth is we have created these
platforms youtube twitter facebook etc which
they are like the printing press on steroids and
i'm sure you will be aware the printing press when
it was first rolled out on the mass scale caused
200 200 years two centuries of religious warfare
strife conflict and tolerance because suddenly
people were able to questions than that question
the narratives that they were being fed by
their version of the mainstream media at the
time which was the priests the aristocrats etc
they were being told one thing and suddenly you
could read the bible for yourself right yeah and
if you certainly could find that there's nothing
in the bible about you know bending the knee to to
your priest or whatever was the you know whatever
it was that those divides were at the time so um
to me that the technological part of it is also
a big part of it and look the technology is so
immensely powerful i don't think any of us have
really worked out how it should be controlled
or regulated because you know in the early days
of the internet it was a kind of wild wild west
and while i enjoyed it and to me that was fun i
also think that the world we live in now to just
say there should be absolutely no restrictions on
anything on the internet is a little bit naive and
impractical that's also not going to happen right
the ability to disseminate information that
has very significant impact on the real world
is so huge now that i think what we're all
struggling with is how does that need to be
controlled without infringing on people's rights
but also with an understanding of the tremendous
power of these tools there's so much to uncover
and break down and as you talk i'm like writing
like words and things and there's something that
you spoke about um you touched on the church right
so the church versus more information which
kind of took away their power um something which
is really a really interesting distinction which
i've noticed between the uk and the usa is the usa
has this patriotism for the flag and freedom and
then so on that's kind of self-explanatory in the
uk we're not really allowed to be patriotic
i don't know if you've noticed that as an
immigrant or whatever but we're sort of not really
allowed to be patriotic here and the way in which
we show our patriotism is through our social
services our national health service our nhs
and this is this is something which spooked
me so you can tell me how you feel about it
so during like the key moment of the lockdown
last year um every thursday night at 8 pm it
was became a ritual everybody would go outside
and clap for the national health service now
i found it odd because it's very like number one
what does that do doesn't really do anything okay
it kind of creeped me out because they can't
hear you it doesn't do anything it doesn't
add any value to it and it's like group thing
it's like doing something for no reason doing
something for the sake of doing and then it's like
you're bowing down to a higher power higher power
which you're actually not allowed to criticize in
the uk like if you criticize the nhs that is akin
to criticizing the church back in the day is there
something going on there like what is up with that
you know especially we can move on to talking
about the pandemic and everything that's going
on and lockdowns and vaccine passports because
that obviously is a huge topic right now but
we are literally not allowed to have freedom of
speech like we are literally not allowed to say
hang on why were nhs health workers you know
dancing on tick tock if you know whatever it
is you're just not allowed to say it i wonder
if you have any opinion on patriotism the nhs
being akin to the church in today's world yeah
there's a lot to unpick there there's quite a
bit i disagree with you on actually yeah but um
so to me the clapping for the nhs i i think i
might have clapped a few times and probably not
very much but to me i don't have a problem in a
pandemic with people giving nurses and doctors the
feeling that they're extra appreciated in a time
when there's an extra strain and an extra risk to
being a worker and nhs i have many friends who are
doctors and nurses uh i personally didn't see that
as a particularly nefarious thing uh where i would
definitely agree with you and i'm writing my first
book called an immigrant's love letter to the west
uh it was initially titled an immigrant's love
letter to britain and it's really all about
this thing that you're raising which
is the inability to to be patriotic
george orwell wrote about this way back when he
said you know there's a certain thing in britain
that uh among intellectuals among the british
intelligentsia that they would rather be seen
stealing from the poor box than standing
to attention during the national anthem
right there's this self-loathing that's always
been very popular in britain which i don't
understand i'm not you know i'm probably more
patriotic about britain than most british people
yeah because i just i think it's a great country
and i think uh it's to be respected but look
there's a lot there's a lot going on underneath
the surface of that and i think one part of that
is there's a certain discomfort with the idea of
patriotism because people have somehow tied into
tied it into like hardcore nationalism and people
think that if you love your country that means
you hate everybody else and you are against other
people and particularly in a multi-ethnic society
as britain is there is the sort of feeling that
somehow being patriotic about britain is tied
into being pro-white or somehow excluding of other
minorities so that's why people then seek these
things like the nhs because that's not something
you can accuse of being like nationalistic in that
way right and and there's this deep it's amazing
how for a society is probably the least racist
society in the world there's this deep discomfort
with any sort of pride or patriotism about your
country whereas to me the history of britain is
overcoming the those boundaries and those terrible
things that happened in the past whether that's
the atrocities committed by the british empire
or slavery or how generations of migrants were
treated when they came in the 50s and 60s and look
at look at us now look how much better society
is right to me that's a story to be proud of
and to me the british identity like the american
identity the american identity even more so is
brilliant in this way because the moment you set
foot in america and you say i buy into the valleys
of your country i want to pursue my dreams i want
the freedom and the risk that comes with freedom
to do what i want to do for the betterment of me
and my family i want to contribute to the society
i want to build things i want to learn things i
i want to create things and i am now an american
and it doesn't matter if you're brown black
green yellow white whatever it doesn't matter
the moment you buy into the idea you become
american and to me that is what the british
culture should be as well yeah you don't have
you don't have to be a particular color or gender
or whatever to be british the british identity
should be these are the things that we believe
but dare ask claire dare ask a normal standard
british person what are british values they will
run away from you like you've just asked them to
join the bnp because that is the attitude that
people in this country have to patriotism to them
any idea of being you know being proud of your
country or thinking that it's actually quite a
good country that it has values that are important
to them that is scary that is absolutely scary and
that's something i would love to change i would
love to make it okay for people to have a healthy
love for their country in this country which
frankly is quite merited if you compare this
country to many others around the world oh yeah
this country you know look the west is great
well was great i don't know where we're going
we'll talk about it in a minute but absolutely
and i i think you know so many people especially
from you know eastern europe run to the uk given
all the atrocities that we've seen throughout the
20th century and how that is you know that is
still it's still sort of existing today the um
the the after effects of it and so on but yeah you
make a really good point and the point actually is
the difference between multi-culturalism
and multi-ethnicity and things like that
because culturalism is a disaster multiple exactly
completely different yeah exactly and you can't
have these conversations and you may like i think
what you said is entirely spot on you know like
come to a country add value build if you want
to make a better life for yourself please make
a better life yourself use use the country
soak up everything you could possibly can but
don't come to a country and try and impose
everything that you're running away from
and if you do it you know if it's to be honest
it's kind of like we're getting to a point
even even you know forget immigration but like
just within a society where nobody is able to
um just accept each other for what they are
everything has to be imposed now you know and
i feel even our language is changing our language
is having to be shifted and imposed no it's
it's she her it's they them you know it's not
just like him her done you know everything is
gone the thing with the thing with language is
i've written some articles about this and again
this will be something i i talk about in my
book it's do you know where the term political
correctness comes from no i actually don't tell
me the term political correctness it never had
anything to do with snowflakes and all this other
stuff that people like to say the term political
correctness comes from the soviet union and
it was also being used in maoist china and
the point of the term politically correct is to
shut someone up if someone says a blatant truth
you could say well comrade this is factually
correct but it is politically incorrect which
means it is inconvenient to the party for you
to be saying this thing that is true right
so political correctness comes the point of
political correctness is to prevent ideas which
are factually accurate from being expressed to
prevent offending or upsetting or challenging the
mainstream narrative of the dogma of that society
in the present time and look at the language i
mean you talk about she her and that's that's a
bit of a niche issue but look at other things so
think about things like tolerance right the most
the people who are the most quote-unquote tolerant
right tolerate no opposition to their views right
the people who bang on endlessly about diversity
don't want anyone with a difference of opinion
in their space the people who want a safe space
what does a safe space looks like look like it's
a space in which people like me and you would be
unsafe right it's a place where people like me and
you would not be welcome when people talk about
welcoming a welcoming space or being welcoming
what they really mean is this is a place where
people who think like us come together to have our
conversation and we don't engage in robust debate
we don't engage in discussion so what has happened
in the last 20 30 years is all of these words have
had their meanings entirely substituted tolerance
now means intolerance diversity now means people
with different skin colors who all think the
same thing right welcoming now means excluding
people and inclusion means excluding people
who don't agree with you so what has happened
linguistically over the last 15 20 years is a
complete substitution of meaning on a grand level
and this is one of the things that george carlin
who we mentioned earlier the comedian he talked
about this a lot he talked about how politicians
and political activists and actors use language to
misrepresent the meaning of what's happening and
to conceal the truth to conceal the truth even the
multiculturalism of multi-ethnic that's why this
distinction is so important a multi-ethnic society
is a society in which people from different races
come together and live peacefully together under
one culture they're all british they're all
american they're all russian they're all this
they're all that right a multicultural society
what that really means is it's not a society
it's a it's disparate groups of people who coexist
in the same geographical space but don't actually
have an overarching identity that they can bind
themselves into and that is a recipe for disaster
and that is a recipe frankly for conflict because
if you allow people to live in the same space but
remain tribally different that will inevitably pit
them against each other and that's what we've seen
in recent times particularly every time anything
happens in in israel and in gaza suddenly you see
that jews are now being attacked in a way that
they've never been and look i'm not someone who
bangs on about my jewishness at all it's not
that important to me i'm not religious i just
noticed that as a very easy example to observe
about what happens when you tribalize people and
you allow everybody to to live in in a society
that's really that they're not really a part of
that they're not integrating into in many like it
was shock to me when i went into my local surgery
gp surgery in london and they gave me a leaflet
in 25 different languages and i was like wait i
thought we lived in britain right i thought we're
we're all here to be british now of course you
know i'll bring my russian cynical our background
into it and someone else will bring their food and
someone else will bring this and that and whatever
uh and that's great but we're all here to learn
the language we're all here to buy into the values
we're all here to to buy into a certain mindset uh
you know and we have the freedom within that
to be different of course we do but yeah but
we're all buying into a certain set of
things and the moment you don't do that
i think that's a recipe for very dangerous things
to happen i think your perspective is fascinating
because you are an immigrant that is why it's so
fascinating you're like don't accommodate for me
don't change your language for me i will be
i'm happy to accept your values that is why
my family left i'm really fascinated i think
you're yeah you know when it comes to like
issues on feminism for example i feel like because
i'm a woman i'm allowed to talk about it you know
if you're black you're allowed to talk about
racism you're an immigrant you're literally
allowed to say why do you have all these languages
this is britain find that fascinating um i have
a question for you something which i didn't
think i would ask you but i'll ask you anyway
um so you spoke about obviously you spoke about
being jewish um it's really interesting um my
audience i don't even know if they know or not but
i am jewish and i don't really talk about it much
um mainly because i hate identity politics so much
hate it with every bone in my body i think it's an
absolute scam of which i was recently scammed
by but we can talk about that at another time
oh yeah um but okay you talk about safe spaces
now when we talk about minorities jewish people
don't fall into that which is fascinating to
me so you know jewish people don't fall into um
the you know either you're the woman black asian
gay lgbt we really don't fall into that like
left-wing protected bubble at all why is that
not that i want to i could not care less please
no one misunderstand me i do not care i'm
happy just to like deal with myself and look
after myself but why don't we why aren't
we allowed in that like protected bubble
well if you think historically about this issue
what is the most oppressed group in the history
of humanity i don't know i don't like to answer
that question i i mean i probably know the
answer but i won't answer it you can answer it
well i'm only asking this because i think it's
it highlights the ridiculousness of of the
conversation around the issue of oppression right
i would be saying this very same thing if i
weren't jewish i just think jews are a very
good example of this conversation so jews
have been persecuted for what two millennia
uh including 70 years ago an attempt to
eradicate all of them from the planet earth and
succeeding largely in taking out about 40 i think
it was of the total jewish population of the world
in the space of six years right so to me that
that i mean that of all the claims to oppression
i would say that's pretty high up there and by
the way while the nazis were exterminating jews in
germany and in eastern europe uh it's not like in
the soviet union where i come from jews were loved
and revered and whatever the the slogan in russia
was kill the jews save russia right so this is a
minority that has been attacked beaten murdered
persecuted for millennia now jews as you rightly
say don't seem to qualify for that persecution
status and i i don't want it i don't that's what
i'm saying neither do i i don't want this crap
and i don't see the world through being jewish
it's not actually that relevant to me i just
it's interesting to me that that this same thing
will is already happening with asian americans
in particular uh the korean the chinese uh and
and the reason of course is the jews despite being
the most oppressed minority in history uh just
like the asian americans who japanese americans
were interred in america during world war ii
they were literally put in camps right and still
they're literally one of the most high earning
demographics in america why is that because of
their culture because of their practices because
they they value education they prioritize success
uh you know all the tropes about jewish mothers
and fathers and you know what what a good jewish
girl and good jewish boy looks like that's culture
and that culture teaches you that it's important
to get a good education it's important to
work hard it's important to be successful it's
important to to make money all of these things
drive a group of people forward and allow them
to thrive despite the fact that they face genuine
obstacles in their advancement right uh so the
the problem that the jews and asian americans
and others increasingly face is that if you're
successful you don't fit the identity politics
ideology because identity politics ideology is
based on victimhood and it's based on failure
right if you're not doing well you are therefore
uh oppressed and if you're doing well well you
can't be oppressed right even if you are even
if you are if literally half of your people have
just been killed well you're still doing well
because you make a lot of money and whatever
i think that's it just doesn't fit the stupid
narrow-minded ideology and so that's why they have
to cast out asian americans they discriminate them
against uh against asian americans in education in
the united states you literally have to have
a higher score on your test to go to harvard
if you're asian-american than you do if you're
white or if you're black or if you're latino
so there's active discrimination going on because
it doesn't fit into the little identity politics
heads that your your oppression and your success
levels aren't necessarily connected because
the main point of of i think this conversation
should be layers if you work hard and if you
do certain things and if you study and you get
a good education you can be successful even if
you are genuinely disadvantaged and instead of
telling people that instead of telling people
you can make it you can be successful
just follow these steps instead they need
people to be quote unquote oppressed they need
people to struggle because then they from their
elite perch can look down upon those people and
say i am speaking on your behalf in my 300th pound
thousand pound a year diversity job at the bbc
i am looking after you poor oppressed person
as i sip my shabbly in a trendy london bar right
that is what it's about it's it's a scam like you
say it's it's an industry diversity inclusion all
of this stuff it's an industry for elite people
mostly elite white people to advance their own
career you put that so wonderfully um that was
absolutely brilliant i totally agree with you it
literally is if you tell somebody from day one
that you are oppressed you are screwed i saw this
video of um mila kunis and ashton kutcher i don't
know if you know the video i'm talking about but
for those who don't know the video it was terrible
terrible this is what happened they've got two
kids i've got a girl and a boy and they said that
they said to their son that they will always take
their daughter to bed first and read her a bedtime
story because outside of their little house girls
don't get to go first you so basically are saying
to their daughter you are going to be oppressed
when you grow up in society therefore we are
going to level the playing field and let you go
to bed first you get the kiss good night first
i mean that is so detrimental it is so
unbelievable i have two brothers and one
of my brothers literally like if i say i can't do
something he will scream at me like i'm in trouble
if i say i can't do something um you know if i
say yeah but it's easier for you because you're
a man i am in trouble if i do that and that
mentality that alternative kind of brainwashing
and indoctrination of you can do anything
regardless of what you look like or your
gender or anything has helped me do what i
do nothing nothing can stop me now because
no you know i don't if you know if somebody
laughs at me for being female or whatever it is
nothing bothers me now because i know that i can
do that i can do whatever i want to do because
i've been told that i can literally indoctrinating
somebody with the mindset that you're going to
fail in society is going to hate you and destroy
you destroys you and that keeps people hooked
yeah yeah yeah and anyone who does that
to children uh that to me is child abuse
anyone who indoctrinates children with the
ideology of failure is abusing that child and
is damaging them for life and is having a huge
impact on their life chances as well because so
much of life not everything in life you know bad
things happen to good people and all of that but
so much of life is about resilience it's about the
willingness to keep going and i learned that the
hard way you know like i said when i was sleeping
on the street and all of these my life was very
very difficult but it never occurred to me that
you wouldn't i wouldn't be able to turn around
even in that moment when when i felt so down i
just knew that you know that's not my destiny
my destiny is to make make a success of my life
and if something isn't happening there's i'm not
saying it's all down to me but there is something
i can do differently to improve that situation
and if you're not teaching your children that
i think you're not setting them up for the best
opportunity in life so it's good for you to have
a brother with some toxic masculinity i suppose
oh yeah he's full of toxic masculinity we support
toxic masculinity in our family no absolutely i
you know i really i really appreciate what you
said i think that is that's what it comes down
to um you know meritocracy pulling yourself up
nobody's coming to save you um but let's move on
to talk about today's world because we have seen
what is going on to me is is really concerning
um i don't mean to be doom and gloom and i really
don't want to be and i you know i do hope that
things can turn around and i genuinely think
that things will turn around eventually
but we have seen lockdowns these vaccine passports
are going to be mandatory and it's odd because you
can't have a conversation about this and for
me it's just so obvious why a vaccine passport
is not a good thing you know what about body
autonomy what about what the left said when it
comes to abortion the left told me that as a woman
i have a right to choose right i my body my choice
that's what the left told me but now the left
is telling me that it's not my body my choice so
what is your take what is going on you
know is there a light at the end of this
authoritarian tunnel well see i wish that you were
right when you say it's the left that won this
yeah you're right i'm sorry it's not just the
left it's actually quite a lot of people on the
right as well uh it's uh what we've seen and i
know you want this to be a positive conversation
and i am someone who is naturally naturally
extremely optimistic about things okay like
we've just talked about i believe that anything
can be overcome i don't agree with you the vaccine
passports are going to be mandatory we're going
to fight and i think we're going to win that fight
i think they are they are claiming that they're
going to introduce them in order to scare young
people into getting the vaccine which by the
way my position on the vaccine is like this if
you're elderly or if you're vulnerable for
clinical reasons if i were in your position
i would definitely take the vaccine right if
you want to take the vaccine great good for
you if you are young and healthy and not at risk
i think you should assess the risks and rewards of
taking the vaccine on its own merits i think
the only possible reason to take the vaccine
is your own medical needs right your own medical
needs to protect you that is why you would take
the vaccine or not take the vaccine so for an
elderly person or a clinically vulnerable person
taking a vaccine makes sense to me on a reward
and risk ratio basis right for a younger person
i think the choice is more difficult and
people should make their own decision on that
but the vaccine passports and dominic crabb our
foreign secretary said this explicitly yesterday
are designed to coerce young people into taking
the vaccine now this is deeply unethical because
what this does is it changes the relationship
between the state and the citizen and the way it
does that is what they're really saying is we're
going to take away your natural rights your right
to go to a club or to a pub or to associate with
others or to see a play or to see a comedy show
or to be out in public or to go to a supermarket
or to go to a concert these are your natural
rights lair that's that's not something boris
johnson invented and assigned to me and you to
be able to do those are god-given rights if you
believe in god or natural rights if you don't
those are things that all human beings have by
virtue of being human and what they're saying is
we're going to take that away from you not because
we need to not because it's for safety not because
we need to protect you other people around you
we're going to take those rights away from you
because it's going to force you to do something
else that we want and this is completely immoral
it's deeply unethical and it opens a pandora's
box of gigantic proportions what about overweight
people if this is about protecting the healthcare
system overweight people put a tremendous amount
of strain and i am so i say this is someone who
used to be overweight a tremendous amount of
strain on the national health service right so
do we take their driving licenses away so they
have to walk everywhere to lose weight is that
the next step because it's the same principle
right it's exactly the principle so it's deeply
unethical now add to that the fact that numerous
government government ministers said repeatedly
that this wouldn't happen the vaccines minister in
britain nadeem zahawi said the vaccine passports
are discriminatory and that they're not going to
introduce them and he gave my friend dan wooden
a guarantee on his show that they wouldn't happen
this is what he said and two months later
they're now trying to sell us on this [ __ ] it's
completely unacceptable it's outrageous but the
problem is and this is where i say even though
i'm optimistic about things personally and i i
cultivate i think a personal resilience that i
think is essential that we've talked about
the thing that i do find very depressing
is not the government the government are always
going to in the crisis they're always going to
clamp down they're always trying to take more
power for themselves they will always do this
the thing that bothers me is the public what we've
seen in the last year and a half is that something
we've always known is the truth right about half
the public uh i don't want to use unkind words
but it's it's hard to avoid they will panic in
the situation of crisis they will be scared and
when they're scared they will throw any principles
they have out of the window and they will demand
that things happen to protect them and it does not
matter what the principles at stakes are at stake
high does not matter what the cost is it does not
matter what the harm is to other people they will
demand that people are forced to do things they
don't want to do it put things in their body that
they don't want to put in there etc because it
makes them feel safer right and that to me is the
tragic side of this we that we've seen is half
the public are absolutely on board we've seen
polls in this country that show 20 of the public
when surveyed are in favor of 10 p.m curfews
even if there is no virus why why why because in
the situation of panic people will quite happily
take your rights away if they think that that
makes them a little bit safer i don't go out
after 10 pm so no one else should be i don't go
to nightclubs 30 say they they would happily close
clubs forever absent a virus layer no virus they
still want clubs to close 30 of the british public
in polls say that right so what we've seen is
the the public in a moment of crisis in a moment
of fear they reveal their inner authoritarianism
these are the same people who were burning witches
these are the same people who were blaming the
jews for the plague these are the same people who
were saluting hitler and i'm not saying they're
nazis at all what i'm saying is these people are
conformist and in a moment of fear and panic they
will go with whatever [ __ ] they're being given
you're absolutely spot on i mean the
thing which concerns me about europe um
is that we don't have the same kind of rights
entrenched often as america so often i talk
about america as this free country and i know
america as well is very much at the heart of
this huge change and division that we're seeing
in society but america still has their first and
second amendment america still has a large
population that are going to say no to this
we don't have that kind of mentality
entrenched here and europe very much
is controlled by its past and its authoritarian
past i know it's not all of europe but it you
know it has those um i was trying to look for the
word earlier it's about like there's like room
like side effects like breadcrumbs from the past
you know and that's what concerns me about the uk
and i wonder if you sort of feel that america's
rights are more entrenched given they have that
first second amendment you know you come in you
come to texas and you try and tell them to inject
themselves with a foreign substance no they'll
show you their guns and they'll tell you to leave
you know it it just has more like i always say
i always say this doesn't need to get into a gun
debate at all i don't really need to get into
that but i always say if jewish people had guns
not just jewish people if everybody if germans
had guns back in the 40s i just don't think the
holocaust would have happened because you even
had germans who wanted to protect jewish people
but obviously couldn't because they didn't have
the means to do that um so i wonder whether you
think you know their rights are more entrenched
just because they have those bill of rights i do i
i i do need to pick you up on the holocaust go
on because it's important and this isn't i i
my position on guns is that if i i personally
don't think that guns in the society make it
better for individuals living in normal times
right i don't okay if i lived in america though
i would definitely own a gun if you live
in a society where guns are allowed i'm
[ __ ] happening yeah it's different you
couldn't implement guns in the uk at all
it's different totally i'm with you no i'm with
you on that but but historically america is what
america is and you're never going to get rid of
the second amendment you just have to accept that
and live with that and that and in that society i
would train to use firearms i would be responsible
with it but i would definitely have firearms right
uh but on the holocaust point just very quickly
it's a little bit simplistic that argument because
uh because the the what happens in societies that
have that sort of authoritarianism totalitarianism
they don't suddenly declare you know what
now we're killing the jews right or now we're
taking people off to the gulags and this is what
alexander solzhenitsyn wrote about he said that if
we'd resisted if we'd resisted and if every time
the kgb came in uh to take someone away we all
ambushed them in the bottom of our building with
axes and guns and frying pans and whatever they
would never been able to do that the problem is
is getting p enough people to rise up against
something like that all at once when they don't
feel personally challenged right and so that's
really the issue because look look look at the
thing with vaccine particles look how many people
now are saying uh what what's your problem look
just take the vaccine just take the vaccine just
take the vaccine part what's your problem with it
so even now let's say that everybody had guns uh
you still wouldn't really be able to do it because
the majority of the public would be on the side of
the tyrannical government if the government became
tyrannical so it's a bit more complicated than
that i i i see the argument there's some merits to
her but i do think it's a little bit more complex
than that but coming back to america i love
america precisely for this very reason that it's
a country that is not entrenched in a particular
way of thinking they still are trying to work out
what is the best way to run a society and they're
not prepared to just throw their freedoms in the
bin because they're a society born of revolution
born of the fight for freedom and so i think that
is something i really admire about our americans
and and in the in in western europe we don't
have that at all in france they're rolling out
these vaccine passports in italy they're having
punch-ups in parliament about it in greece people
are on the streets uh but the governments uh
feel very comfortable i think and part of the
reason no doubt is that the people who are out
in the streets protesting aren't able to cause
anarchy on the mass scale and no one wants any
loss of life at all but i think the government
would be a lot more cautious if they were a
little bit more afraid of their people and i
i don't have a problem with that that's kind of
what i'm getting i feel you know potentially just
going back to that holocaust example if people
were armed i don't know whether the situation
would have escalated or been able to escalate
um you know i know that what happened was very
unprecedented and now we can look back at history
and we can take what we learn and we can say
that reminds me of that that kind of
rhetoric reminds me of that you know
passports mandates i know i know but see in nazi
germany for example the way you would have done it
is very simple you would have said well you know
the jews are a little bit suspect so uh they can't
own uh rifles uh and then the jews are actually
a little bit more suspect they can't own handguns
and then before you know it the jews don't have
any guns anyway with the majority of the public
going along with it right because the majority of
the public won't make a stand on principle they
will only make a stand on what's convenient for
them and i know this is very kind of black pill
from from me in terms of the way i'm communicating
it i'm just saying i i prefer to face the reality
than to have a an overly optimistic view of things
even though naturally i'm very optimistic i just
think you have to stare at the truth in the face
and the truth is the people who will give you
authoritarianism are not corrupt evil politicians
it's the half the population who will go along
with them they're the ones that are making
it happen and as long as they're not on your
side even if you have an ar-15 you're not
really going to be able to do very much about it
yeah you see that it's that point isn't it because
i saw a really funny video of boris johnson the
other day i don't know if you saw the video but
for those watching there was a video of the prime
minister of the united kingdom struggling to
open an umbrella it was hilarious it popped
open it flipped it was so funny and then you look
at this guy and you're like oh my god you're the
person responsible for all this authoritarianism
that we've seen and so two things makes me wonder
like number one is that actually coming from you
you seem like an all-right bloke you know like
i think we could have a great time like you know
just going for a for a chat and a drink whatever
like you know you seem great is it coming from him
is it coming from the people allowing it to happen
is it coming from the eu i do know that you know
this is one of the reasons why people did vote
to leave the eu because of their authoritarian
tendencies which we're clearly seeing with the
vaccine passports rolling out across europe
you know where do you think these overall
this authoritarianism is sort of coming from well
okay consider this think about the british cabinet
i know for your american viewers this may be
a bit of a niche niche thing to get into but
uh if you go down the list of the people who
are in cabinet people like rishi sunak the
the the chancellor the finance minister in
other countries uh sajid javid nadim zahawi
these are all multi multi multi millionaires who
are nonetheless in government right they're taking
a crappy salary they have the the the the official
government salary is almost no money to them at
all right they're taking a tremendous amount of
hatred and flag from the public they're constantly
in the gaze of the media it has a hugely
detrimental effect on their personal lives
on their marriages on their kids on the whole
thing so why are they doing this why why do all
these people want to be in the governing party now
the the the sort of uh the sort of positive vision
is well they want to make a difference they want
to contribute to society yeah well maybe but you
know especially with men men crave power you know
these people are there because they want power
they want to be able to shape the future of the
world and that's at the heart of most human beings
right but these people who who who already have
millions of pounds they're not going into it to
profit financially from some dodgy deal they're
going into it because it's a status competition
for power right so the fact that boris johnson
looks and behaves like a buffoon doesn't mean
that he is a buffoon he's someone who wanted
to be king of the world when he was five this
is a quote direct quote these people are obsessed
with power and they want it and when they get the
opportunity like the last 18 months to exercise
more of it to tell more people what to do to take
more freedoms away in the name of safety and as
they see the public cravenly acquiescing to that
they want more and they can do it and that's
why they're there they're there for the power
they're there for the power and now they've
got it of course they're having a good time
and boris johnson looking like an idiot is no he's
a that's an act boris johnson is a very driven
power hungry man just like the rest of them yeah
it's very interesting i mean i i didn't really
take that approach but i guess you're right
because to be honest like i would love to
make a better world but i don't really it's not
really in me like i don't really have the drive
to want to be a politician for me i just want
to make a better life for myself and my family
so you're right like you can want to make it make
the world a better place but with that has to come
the drive to wanting to be king of the world
um as well like if you think about this if you
were starting from scratch now completely from
scratch and you wanted to make the world a better
place would you go into politics no because
i feel like with politics it's a never-ending
cycle and even if you do make it better it will
just be undone once you're gone right but but
the thing is you're also very constrained if
you wanted to make the world a better place
you'd invent something that stops plastic
building up in the in the in the ocean
right or you you'd help orphans in africa or you'd
build the church or you'd build a school or you'd
do something practical right and these people
are millionaires who could do all of that but
they go into politics right why is that and the
reason is they want the power that it comes with
and so to me the fact that they are now
exercising this this arbitrary power that
they've given themselves there's no surprise of
why to me i'm surprised that people are surprised
you know just because we're coming up towards
the end i will just bring this up now because
i obviously i i really enjoyed the conversation
and i think everything that you've said i i really
really agree you also speak really eloquently
which is really really important when you're
talking about these kind of issues we need people
that can put it forward in a very fair and clear
manner it's really important um but this is
actually you know you talk about what would
you do if you wanted to change the world this is
a huge reason as to why i'm hugely involved in
cryptocurrency mainly bitcoin and why literally
that's now the foundation of my life and my my
career and my let's say humanitarian work because
i do regard it as that it's so wonderful to
have something which literally allows you
to opt out something which governments
can't control like they can't control your
money the eu want to make cryptocurrency um
they want to ban anonymous cryptocurrency
transactions so i don't obviously i don't
know how much you know about cryptocurrency but
ultimately they are technology at the top remember
yes i know you lost your bitcoin you lost your
bitcoin you sold your bitcoin sorry i didn't
lose it i got it you sold it for it no okay yeah
which would be now around like 60 grand but anyway
40 grand but anyway another time um but for me
having cryptocurrency is is such a lifesaver it
it really brings me so much peace during a time
like this um so before we went live i was telling
you i was going i was having a bit of a rant and
my rant was about central bank digital currencies
because they are coming and essentially they will
be an extension of the current monetary system
but they will take away any extra privacy or
anonymity that we had left and it's just another
way for governments to just basically screw you
over and that is why i find so much peace in
cryptocurrency in bitcoin um and for me like that
is where the love comes from a lot of people are
like i'm in it for the tech and i'm like now i'm
in it for the politics i'm in it for the freedom
in it for the revolution um would you ever like
consider going more down that route in any manner
well it's one of the things that we think
about quite carefully at trigonometry because
while we are not people who put out content
that's you know likely to get banned or likely
to get taken down from youtube i mean we do
have controversial conversations sometimes
but i think we stayed fairly within the the sort
of overton window uh we're pushing the boundaries
of it every now and again but i i think we
we have a responsible approach to what we
do uh but but but the reality is that we don't
know what the truth what the what the situation
will be we've seen people banned from various
platforms in the past past and and obviously
the the the the bigger you get the
more uncancelable you become right like
the point i started was if if anybody
said anything bad about me in a newspaper
that would have had a detrimental impact on
my comedy career right now i don't depend
on anything like that the only thing i depend
on is the existence of youtube to do our show
and ways to convert that into cash that i can
spend now if the government at some point decide
to start shutting down bank accounts of people
who've got the wrong opinions you can totally see
how an alternative way of paying for things
and receiving money from our supporters and
whatever would work so i i can totally see it's
just not something that i know enough about but
as someone who's who understands the context of
everything else it it makes perfect sense that
you'd want to have a way a medium of exchange that
isn't controlled by government uh the only thing
that i would say on that front and again this
may be the black pill element of my thinking is
nothing you nothing that allows people to
keep money out of the hands of government
will ever remain unregulated for
very long they will find a way
so on that note and i totally understand where
you're coming from but this is why bitcoin is so
beautiful and i i really use the word beautiful i
know i sound crazy but i've written a book on this
and it's coming out really soon i'm so excited
you just look forward to reading it thank you so
much likewise i think the name of your upcoming
book sounds absolutely brilliant um that is such
a smart a love letter from an immigrant i think
you said it was it's really really smart um but
essentially you just can't ban a decentralized
network that is the beauty and the genius of
it like china for example tried to ban it they
shut down um mining in many different provinces
of course it had had an effect on the price but
the price still remained above its all-time high
of twenty thousand dollars back in 2017 um and
now miners are literally just moving they're
just relocating plugging in a different place and
we're starting to see the technology sort of kick
back up again like the hash rate difficulty
adjustment things like that we're starting to
see that come back and the price is starting to
recover and that is what's so beautiful about it
and i think as well like you know with politics
on a grand scale states governments provinces
organizations companies will have to pick a side
as we move forward and i think we're seeing that
anyway like not the entire world has gone into
lockdown some places you know are totally open
and totally free so i do think that some states
organizations nightclubs when it comes to vaccine
passports will pick aside and so that is where the
miners bitcoin miners to help secure the network
we'll move to should governments really try um i
think that i think it's it's it's honestly amazing
and it really gives me hope um so yeah if you ever
want to talk more about it just let me know but um
but i just want to say thank you so much um
honestly it's been such a good conversation
where can people find out more about you and also
what are you up to in the next few months well i'm
at constantin kitchen on on twitter and other
social media the show that i do with my co-host
francis is trigonometry as in trigger like a gun
trigger uh we put out interviews with absolutely
fascinating people everybody from your jordan
petersons to completely unknown people who have
an interesting uh story and we also do uh four
raw shows a week where it's just me and him two
comedians uh very politically and correctly
joking about the things that are going on
uh and being problematic in all sorts of
different ways uh so yeah that i do that i'm
on gb news once a week on thursdays as well you
can there's plenty of me if you look and my book
is called an immigrant love letter to the west
and it's coming out next year i am so excited
to read that honestly constantine i want to
thank you so much it's been such a pleasure
um guys please follow um constantine he
always is offering incredible insight
and um i saw that you're on gb news that is super
cool gb news for those that don't know is this new
new uk kind of alternative ish media it's a
bit more refreshing than the usual news thanks
for having me absolute pleasure guys thanks for
tuning in and i will see you all next week bye
bye